[Music]
on this Thursday night Canada's Deputy
Prime Minister in her own words
Christian freeland's fears about the
so-called Freedom Convoy that was a
heart-stopping quote for me for
Testimony at the emergencies act inquiry
Children's Hospitals canceling critical
surgeries they don't have enough beds
they don't have enough staff Mountain
frustration and Desperation among
parents propaganda dripping with sarcasm
[Music]
how Russian State TV is targeting Canada
and remembering a hockey hero the great
foreign tributes for the NHL defenseman
who broke barriers and shattered records
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight for a Nasser good
evening thanks for joining us tonight
we're getting perhaps the clearest
Insight so far into the liberal
government's rationale and invoking the
emergencies act last winter during the
Convoy protest in Ottawa the inquiry
looking into the controversial decision
is now in its final days but during the
past few weeks Canadians have been given
a rare glimpse into what was happening
behind the scenes and most recently in
the minds of cabinet ministers as they
tried to find ways to control it today
Canada's Deputy Prime Minister wrapped
up her testimony
the longer it went on the greater threat
that the U.S would lose faith in us and
our trading relationship would be
irreparably damaged I realized
as a country somehow we had to find a
way to bring this to an end
Christian Freeland says action was
desperately needed from Ottawa with new
documents revealing American investors
considered Canada a joke and a Banana
Republic as protests continued our chief
political correspondent David Aiken has
tonight's top story
as the Deputy Prime Minister and Finance
Minister Christopher freeland's Chief
concern is the state of Canada's economy
[Applause]
and she feared last Winter's border
blockades especially in Windsor could
result in irreparable harm we can't let
Canada be devastated this way she phoned
U.S President Joe Biden's most
influential economic adviser Brian deese
who told her that the Windsor blockade
was about to force all car plants in the
northeastern U.S to shut down she
emailed her Deputy ministers saying
decent the Americans were quote very
very very worried that was a dangerous
moment for Canada she said our neighbors
saw the blockades and Canada's inability
to clear them as a vulnerability to
American Supply chains and that's a
problem for us because there are plenty
of Americans both Democrats and
Republicans who would love any excuse to
impose more protectionist measures on us
Freeland convened a zoom call with the
CEOs of Canada's banks for advice one
told Freeland that Canada was seen as a
quote joke by business colleagues in the
states and learned an American investor
told that CEO they refused to quote
invest another red Cent In Your Banana
Republic in Canada that was a
heart-stopping quote for me at that
point for Freeland it was a matter of
what Canada could do and do quickly her
Department first turned to the finances
fueling the blockades by creating new
rules and regulations for crowdfunding
platforms like GoFundMe there's this
whole Space where Financial transactions
happen that no one has any line of sight
to and then the most controversial of
measures in the emergencies act the
power to freeze bank accounts of
protesters I would have preferred not to
have had to do this
but in my mind I weigh that against what
I really believe is the tens hundreds of
thousands of Canadian jobs and families
that we protected on Friday the Final
witness to this Saga the Prime Minister
himself will take the stand David Akin
Global News
Ottawa
now to a development in a story Global
News first broke this summer a Veterans
Affairs Canada employee suggested
medically assisted dying to a veteran
who wanted treatment for post-traumatic
stress disorder and a traumatic brain
injury it was shocking Veterans Affairs
said it was an isolated case but now
we're learning that's not true Mackenzie
gray joins me now Mackenzie tell us what
was revealed during the House of Commons
standing committee on Veterans Affairs
today
for a disturbing Revelations from the
veterans affairs minister Lawrence
McCauley his Department finding two
additional instances of a Veterans
Affairs employee inappropriately raising
medical assistance and dying with a
veteran I have instructed the deputy to
examine all options in this
investigation including referring the
matter to the police for investigation
if necessary
I can confirm that the RCMP have been
contacted and the department has taken
steps to formally to formally refer the
case that brings the total instances of
made being discussed by this employee to
four Global News first reported in
August that a Veterans Affairs employee
called a combat veteran who was seeking
treatment for post-traumatic stress
disorder and a traumatic brain injury
raising made as an alternative to
treatment the veteran who Global News is
not identifying says the service agent
brought up medical assistance in dying
repeatedly even after the veteran asked
the service agent to stop and this made
him feel pressured the pressure was so
strong the veteran was concerned that
this may have happened to others the new
revelation comes less than two weeks
after Macaulay told our Mercedes
Stevenson on the west block that the
original allegation was a one-off to my
knowledge at this time there is one
isolated case and but that's a
totally and completely unacceptable the
deputy Minister also told the committee
that the VAC employee in question has
been suspended but didn't say when that
discipline started as for the
investigation it's now been expanded to
look into management and training
practices to determine why the employee
was able to repeatedly raise made with
veterans pharah
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie there are more calls for an
investigation into another explosive
global news report this one about an
Ontario group home chain our
investigative team uncovered allegations
of mistreatment violent physical
restraints and over medication of kids
who lived at group homes run by a
company called hats off these are homes
for kids who have been abused orphaned
or have behavioral issues Carolyn Jarvis
joins us from the Ontario legislature
where there were fireworks yet again
today Carolyn
far the Ontario NDP is calling the Ford
government's handling of the Child
Welfare file a massive failure saying
kids were virtually abandoned once again
today they renewed their calls for an
investigation into hats off speaker will
the minister commit today to a full
investigation into hats off so that no
child spends another day in these
horrific conditions and no more children
die in care yes or no we are improving
the oversight we are improving the
accountability we are improving the
inspections we improving the number of
inspectors we are listening to the
sector the Ford government is in the
midst of a multi-year redesign of the
child welfare system but some experts
say it stops short I'm meeting the needs
of kids in care
what sort of response are you getting
outside of Queens Park
well this week we heard from more former
workers from hatsoff who said they too
witnessed what they called abuse and
neglect some spoke of the overuse of
restraints and Punishment hatsoff says
that restraints are only used as a last
resort when someone's safety is at risk
as for the allegations of over
medication they said that they rely on
Health Care Professionals well speaking
of hats off Carolyn do you have any
sense of how this investigation is being
received
well just this afternoon they wrote
saying the allegations being made are
unfounded and misleading but they can't
counter them because of confidentiality
reasons they say they've always passed
inspections and the ministry has never
found a case of abuse they say they've
reached out to the opposition and the
government to work collaboratively on
how best to protect kids pharah
Carolyn Jarvis I know you'll stay on top
of the story thank you
during this tough cold and flu season
our Health Care system is showing its
cracks parents are facing long wait
times in emergency rooms medication is
in short supply and now critical
pediatric surgeries are being postponed
as calls grow for government Health
officials to step in and do more Heather
York's West speaks with the family of a
boy whose hard surgery has been canceled
twice
Jackson Armstrong has spent a lot of
time in hospital over the years he's had
10 heart surgeries and he's not yet
eight years old his 11th operation was
supposed to take place more than a month
ago and
basically we got told at the end of the
day at three o'clock that Jackson was
being canceled and they were sending us
back home a tough flow for a family that
lives in Kamloops BC four hours away
from BC Children's Hospital in Vancouver
one month later Jackson's rescheduled
surgery was canceled again they don't
have enough beds they don't have enough
staff and basically surgeries are not
really happening at this point a surge
of viral illnesses amongst kids is
overwhelming Children's Hospitals across
the country creating a crisis in
Pediatric Care comparable to what adult
hospitals faced during the height of the
covid-19 pandemic yes we are where icus
across the country have reached capacity
emergency departments are full there's
no beds for the kids to go while most
children do recover from these viral
illnesses so far this season two
children have died from the flu it's why
this week a group of parents and
Physicians sent an open letter to the
premiers and prime minister stating we
are currently in an unprecedented crisis
in which kids lives are on the line
there is a palpable sense of
hopelessness amongst parents and those
that serve kids on the front lines yet
we see no tangible signs of action like
requiring masks and doors vaccinating
our children and encouraging people to
stay home when sick which often requires
paid sick days with the spread of these
infectious diseases not yet at their
Peak children's hospitals are bracing
for more difficult weeks to come so
while Jackson Armstrong's heart surgery
is now scheduled for mid-December his
mom fully expects it will be canceled a
third time Heather your Express Global
News Calgary
Ottawa says a new climate adaptation
strategy will help communities face
flooding fires and devastating storms
the funding commitment supposed to help
people flee disaster and then get back
into their homes faster as Eric Sorensen
reports it's all part of an effort to
bring down the cost of climate change
before it balloons any bigger
the storm that devastated Atlanta Canada
this fall was one more high-cost
disaster made worse by climate change a
year ago the Deluge and flooding in BC
cost more than seven billion dollars
from flooding to wildfires and heat
waves the impacts from global warming
are growing more intense more frequent
and more expensive the message from Twin
announcements on the east and west
coasts Canada must adapt for the first
time a truly National direction for
preparing for climate change events
across this country by investing in a
more resilient can we can make a real
difference a comprehensive plan will add
1.6 billion dollars to ottawa's climate
plans to reach across Canadian Society
in biodiversity and human health better
infrastructure and better forecasting
working with indigenous communities and
all levels of government when we live in
a climate constrained world like we do
now almost everything we do is climate
adaptation building stronger communities
is not just about infrastructure it's
making our communities more Equitable
and more just new Investments include
164 million dollars for flood Hazard
Maps so Canadians can access up-to-date
risks 284 million to mitigate wildfires
including a new center for Wildland fire
Innovation plus Millions for guidance
and resources for Canadians confronting
extreme heat to accelerate codes and
standards for more resilient
infrastructure and to help Coastal and
Northern Communities be more climate
resilient
the aim of spending now is to bring down
the ultimate cost of climate damage
that's forecast to reach 15 billion
dollars a year by 2030. we're paying
over two billion dollars a year in in
insurance claims which is up 400 percent
from where we were 15 years ago so uh
the cost of inaction on climate change
is far higher than the cost of action
with our vast forests that can burn so
many waterways that flood the world's
longest coastline confronting rising sea
levels and a melting Arctic Canada faces
climate adaptation challenges as diverse
as any country in the world Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
Russia gets riled up
coming up how State TV is taking aim at
Canada
Russia's top state broadcaster has
picked up a global news exclusive about
an Ontario company making an impact in
Ukraine nine months into the war it
appears Russia is ramping up as Mike
droley reports the propaganda machine is
accusing Canada of playing an active
part in the war
you might be surprised by the top story
on Russia's most popular news program we
were it's about Canada and its apparent
hostility towards Russia presenter Olga
scabieeva accuses Canada of fueling the
war in Ukraine which she sarcastically
calls an international crisis she then
airs a translated portion of a global
news report on canadian-built armored
personnel carriers making a difference
in Ukraine
our report first aired on the new
reality without the aggressive rock
music or the overt political spin
applied by Russia's propaganda machine
that's a completely torqued view of the
truth and if Russia were to pull out
as it should
a sovereign country can continue to
exist
if Ukraine were to stop fighting
Ukraine would cease to exist
and that's the reality Roman shimanov is
the CEO of Rochelle which is so far sent
over 100 of its Senator vehicles to
Ukraine eight were bought by Canada the
Rest by NATO and European allies in our
story shimanov says he'd pop open a
bottle of champagne when Putin lost the
war Russia Juan skebayeva told her
viewers he had a drinking problem
because I guess in the many Russian
Minds uh the best way to make a person
to show him negative ways to associate
them with the alcohol the Kremlin
controls Russian State TV using
misinformation to further the narrative
that its invasion was just creating
enemies where none exists is a tactic
Vladimir Putin has used for decades it
fits the Kremlin narratives to suggest
that Canada is working with these
Ukrainian War mongers ukrainians who've
been identified by Russian State media
as being you know neo-nazis satanists
um that they're constantly looking for
ways along with NATO
to attack Russia shimanov says it's
important they not lose sight of who
created the propaganda in the first
place Mike Droid Global News Toronto
popcorn Fury ahead the chaos consuming
the world's biggest iPhone Factory
[Music]
China's had a strict zero coveted policy
throughout the pandemic despite this a
record 30 000 new infections were
recorded in one day this week the harsh
rules have led to Violent protests
including at the world's largest iPhone
Factory where more than 200 000 people
work but as Mike Armstrong reports it's
not just the lockdown causing anger
they are images that rarely make it out
of China open descent
protesters facing off with police at a
factory some have called iPhone City
it's where Foxconn the world's biggest
Tech manufacturer makes products for
Apple the world's most valuable company
with the protests this week are over pay
well it's quite extraordinary Joshua
Freeman has studied Mega factories
around the globe he says this one is
basically a campus employees work sleep
and eat on site conditions are difficult
and the work repetitive in 2010 there
was a wave of suicides the company
actually put up nets to catch workers
who jumped from buildings more recently
the issue has been over rigid covered
protocols and lockdowns last month some
workers simply walked off the job and
left the company had to go on a hiring
Blitz Pakistan recruited a whole new
group of workers and those workers this
second group who are protesting right
now
protesters argued the company wasn't
paying bonuses they were promised and
there were claims workers were
quarantined without food
Wednesday managers called in police to
force workers back well the company is
now apologizing blaming a technical
error during the hiring process now this
latest problem may be over salaries but
kovids being the complication China's
pursued a rigid zero coveted policy
observers say and not done enough in
terms of vaccinations it's impacting
Mental Health and Welfare and eventually
the country will have to open up they
have had very small numbers of deaths
and in my mind it should be the number
of deaths that drive the decision to to
have a lockdown that has so much
collateral collateral damage
now in China news of the protests is
censored but internationally the Optics
aren't good critics say apple has put
itself in a difficult situation with an
extreme dependence on China as a
manufacturer and as a consumer Market
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
Maple Leafs Legend Max remembering boria
salming who paved the way for Europeans
to play in the NHL
thank you
a sad day in the hockey worlds former
Toronto Maple Leaf boria salming has
died at the age of 71. he was a Pioneer
who helped change hockey psalming
started his career in the Rough and
Tumble NHL of the 70s he was one of very
few Europeans drafted in a league at the
time so getting on the ice for him meant
discrimination haters pushed he pushed
back and it was that toughness that made
him a fan favorite who eventually paved
the way for the hockey stars of today
for a generation of hockey fans he was a
star from a far away land with a style
all his own battle does Salman he's been
lucking it well Moria salming was a
hockey Trailblazer
well he came over sort of as breaking
the Swedish barrier Bob stellick spent
20 years with the Leafs and saw teams
try to intimidate salming with violence
it was a very tough time in the National
Hockey the mid 70s Philadelphia Flyer
goon hockey was was a big part of the
league then uh I remember boria talked
about his one of his first games it was
against the Flyers and he ended up
getting jumped by Dave the hammer
Schultz women played fielded when you
close to their bench they were standing
up and screaming they're going to kill
him you know you've got a lot a lot of
cheap shots he took the abuse gave it
back and excelled in 16 Seasons with the
blue and white salming piled up more
points than any Toronto defenseman
before or since he's still the franchise
assist leader in Sweden salming has long
been revered known as the king he was
the country's first player inducted into
the Hockey Hall of Fame known here for
his sense of humor I think my nose is a
little crooked today
welcome accompanied by his family number
21
borea salming
[Applause]
salming was just in Toronto for Hall of
Fame weekend now suffering the effects
of ALS better known as Lou Gehrig's
disease the disease left psalming unable
to speak but the moment needed no words
but what a gesture we are about to see
from Sheldon Keith who will start all
six swedes to believe lineup tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another powerful illustration of
salming's profound influence at enduring
Legacy boria salming was 71.
and that's global national for this
Thursday night I'm foreign osser on
behalf of our entire crew I want to
thank you for spending part of your
evening with us and we want to leave you
tonight with the Statue of Foria salming
outside Scotiabank Arena where
attributes growing as people leave notes
and flowers and pay their respects until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night
foreign
[Music]